[Music]
one more shot and the building goes down
take care of that tank
uh sound
what's that
action
[ __ ] we have a dialogue theme
cuts to me i'm like got it and i spin
around the corner cuts the hip fire shot
rehearsal
boom action
going hot ready ready we're going up
we're
i felt that like go into my pants in my
shirt
that was awesome
nick could you catch that i got it
um that's sam what
you take moves you start like you take
turret moves and you start burning it i
just i just get out to the back and we
see it's kind of like over here now so
why did you shoot the gym
he's aiming that way i'm like hey oh
look over here and on the inside the
guy's like huh get the turn away from
your building oh yeah yeah he's aiming
at this over here
yeah makes sense
audio speeds camera speed
hey guys in your movie
hey get out of that shot
action
we should have a shot where it's like me
running like
the camera looks at me and i like run
out of frame he's like
you know he's like trying to see me but
he can
sam
keep going keep going keep going get
going get in there get in there
[ __ ] going going like that going like
that i can't
very complicated what it arguably yes it
was yeah it was i mean we had like
all right someone died yeah
yo take us
this thing is sweet
what i'm sorry i just ruined that
hearing sam inside being like double
tank kill
yeah
like inside of this huge mobile gun
this isn't
it's not like we're just inside of a
you know it's not like we're in a video
game that's not cg
or is it
so it's been a long time since we've
done a collaboration with freddie w it's
about that time of the year again and ea
actually approached us to make a
commercial so
brandon freddy sam and i all teamed up
four directors on a commercial kind of
nutty and we actually put together our
battlefield 3 commercial um it's totally
awesome we threw it together in like
eight days i know we actually
pre-production was two days and then we
shot and now we're doing all the
post-production in like four days so
it's a really tight schedule and they
have a behind the scenes on their
channel that details the entire process
if you guys want to go check it out
anyways it was a really awesome
opportunity kind of one of those like
lifelong goals where we actually got to
work with like full-blown pyrotechnics
professional camera gear it was like our
first time on a project this big and
hopefully there's more to come so
anyways you guys
when you're sitting around watching tv
over christmas vacation you see a
battlefield 3 commercial come up
yeah turn up the volume turn up the
volume
and high five your mom
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
hey
[Music]